In January 2022, Bloomberg reported that the
Federal Trade Commission is investigating Meta
for supposedly anti-competitive conduct concerning
Meta's Oculus headset and app store. If true,
this is another example of antitrust overreach.
Virtual reality and the metaverse are in their
developmental stages. Markets are still sorting out
what services and technologies customers will want.
Yet, amazingly, the investigators apparently
believe that they know what prices should be
and how devices and services should be sold. Such
overreach can severely hamper the metaverse's
growth and development. One concern is about
Oculus's relatively low price. This is misguided.
Sony's headset is about the same price. Even if the
Oculus price is below cost, this is common in the
gaming industry, where companies subsidize consoles
to get customers into the ecosystem. The regulators
should put their investigative resources
elsewhere and let customers drive the metaverse.
What do you think? Is Meta damaging
competition in the metaverse?
Let us know in our poll, and let us know
what other topics you'd like our scholars
to cover in 60 seconds, and be sure to like and
subscribe to more research and videos from AEI.